now this was the scene in washington d.c  just a few hours ago 20 to 30  shots were fired on a popular street  filled with  uh very well-heeled washingtonians  eating at very popular outdoor  restaurants  now it's being reported right now that  two males  have been shot with non-life-threatening  injuries now this shooting comes less  than a week  after gunshots rang out outside  nationals park that sent  fans fleeing the 101 homicides in her  city  should have been a wake-up call on their  own but maybe it'll take  the feathers of the elite getting  ruffled for mayor muriel bowser  to realize that she has a real problem  on her hands hey sean hannity here hey  click here to subscribe to fox news  youtube page  and catch our hottest interviews and  most compelling analysis  you will not get it anywhere else